I don't feel like it was an ultimatum I
don't I think it was heard doing what I
asked every girl to do from the very
first night and that was to be honest to
me and share it was ever on their heart
yeah so Peter Webber and Madison Pruitt
seem to be the only people who didn't
think she gave him a big old ultimatum
on Monday's episode of The Bachelor I
can't change who I am like I can't
change I believe in like what I stand
for what I need here's what Madison told
Peter this before the cast left for the
fantasy suites in Australia next to a
cue word to like sleep with somebody
else like it would be really hard for me
to like move forward in this so what are
you like saying like if if I were just
like like spend the night with someone
else so that's something that you could
do James can be really hard for me
because of you two nobody will ever look
at a windmill the same you know I did
say there was something that Peter and I
did twice it was actually four times but
Madison was careful not to call it an
ultimatum is you're saying you don't
want me to spend or you wouldn't be able
to keep this going with me if I spent
the night with anyone else
just so I can be clear
in no way do I want to like if you like
an ultimatum or like tell you what you
can do I can do it all I can I hope you
know that hope you know my heart but for
me like actions speak louder than words
well I think you can guess where this
one's going right yeah
Peter hit up the fantasy suite with
Hannah Ann and Victoria F before he met
up with Madison again and that's why
Madison dropped this bomb I'm sorry if I
didn't show more in my heart that night
but like coming into this week is really
hard for me for a lot of different
reasons and tonight I want to be as
honest about everything that I can be
growing up I made a comment to myself
and I decided that I wanted to save
myself for marriage
awkward because Peter well he admitted
he did the deed if you know what I mean
like I'll just be very honest and I
won't give any details but I
I have been intimate and
I can't lie to you about that Madison
just took really hurt in there and like
okay I can't change who I am like I
can't change I believe in like what I
stand for what I need like I can't
change that
Peter begged her not to go
no I know I'm not perfect and I quote
you geology see you meet
fans will have to wait for next week's
episode to find out what happens next
but one et caught up with Peter he had
this to say about the whole ordeal okay
let's dig into how things are ending
Madison has given you an ultimatum
watching this footage back how do you
feel watching it do you feel it was fair
that she kept some things from you and
gave you this decision to me I keep
getting asked that and I don't feel like
it was an ultimatum I don't I think it
was her doing what I asked every girl to
do from the very first night and that
was to be honest to me and share what
was ever on their heart and that's what
you did and it trust me it made it for
an insanely incredibly difficult week
for me there's no doubt about that but I
can't fault her for just sharing her
heart are you really in love with three
women you've gotten some criticism for
this yeah I don't know why it's if I
wasn't feeling I wouldn't have said it
so I've always been a firm believer a
little heart wants what it wants
and I think this experience for sure is
show me there's not just one soul mate
out there I think at some point of my
life I used to think that and yeah I've
definitely been able to give my heart to
more than one person so it's possible I
never want this season to end seriously
it's like drama and drama and drama but
of course you can count on ET to keep
you up-to-date on all the latest
bachelor news including Madison's big
decision so make sure to keep it locked
up right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens I'll see you soon